SEPA mio to its best heavyweight of all
time uh yeah there's argument for that
for sure laughter do you do you think
that did you find my way did you find
the way DC was fighting him toward the
end very strange did you feel he was
what DC does but I felt like DC like he
kind of sees red and just keeps coming
forward no not at all he just like DC's
whole thing's like embracing the grind
and ste payout grinded him he just keeps
you've sparred lumps he just keeps
coming forward though he does but but
when we're handed down against TP I
thought to myself he's walking into a
right hand like that
he just didn't respected enough and yeah
eventually caught up with a man you know
yeah eventually caught up with you know
who loses out the most in all this all
right Jon Jones cuz you never you see
John verse DC now know
think how much money he would have made
off that so that's that's out that's
gone John now really the only super
fight left for John John just steeping I
don't think Joe John eat him alive
John woody steep a alive well how do I
even a fight what yeah I was watching on
went oh man I bet John's watch this my
[ __ ] I'll go to heavy really yeah I
would say the opposite how so DC beat
him for every minute of that fight
except for that fourth round yeah you
know what John would do John would I
don't see me landed I don't think John
hits his hardest Daniel and I think
steep a walks him down and oh no way
punch his lights out mmm-hmm no think
about John John was pushing DC back no
one puts his DC back DC bullets deep in
that dead boys deep in the Octagon and
FEMA also think what John well also
judged Daniels 240 pounds in that fight
you know what do you think John upcoming
it
he I guess he walked it off is that how
much he weighs well I read it hmm if I'm
John scam but watch I go oh yeah we'll
go take that belt wow really yeah you
don't think it's a fight I think it's a
good fight but I think John dissect them
eat them alive take them down take again
John took down DC dude yeah multiple
times
yeah he did John beat the [ __ ] out of
him Wow
I do you think that's the fight that
happens if your jaw like the only super
fight for John's that and for if it all
depends what DC is gonna do so let's say
DC retires so the only super fight you
have John steep Bay you have Frances
gone Oh John you have ste paid Frances -
there's not a lot out there for a man so
DC who's not fighting [ __ ] up a lot
for other people but hmm maybe I'm I
might see John as a 205 pound fighter I
don't see him as a heavyweight but you
know he beat DC twice right did be DC
twice handedly yeah knocking him out the
head kick knocked him out excuse me sir
yeah and all dogs bars with this heavy
weights and you can make an argument
almost for DC being the greatest
heavyweight as I'm one correct of all
time Charlie go up there scatter sighs
Cain Velasquez you got to go up there
they just got to pay him to go up there
oh go and match up wise there's nothing
for my light heavyweight there's no so
you don't think John you don't think
John's afraid of steep a god no uh-uh
cuz he messed ebay just flat foot it's
state takes shots he takes shots a lob
and my feeling is he can take he's so
durable he takes anything John gives him
closes that distance and starts punching
him in the face that's that's what
knocks him out in the clear yes Oh cuz
you think oh you think John is a Greco
whose phenomenal in the clinch who
submitted who have submitted Glover
Teixeira in the clinch
Lidl Machida in the clinch beat destroys
guys but destroys guys in the clinch
Steve Bay's not a big heavyweight was he
- you trained them six for six no 6-3
6-3
not sitting 140 big boy he looked very
big when I saw him just wide you know
trying head big head yeah I mean six CS
6-3 they always they always exaggerate
Daniel's not 511 no why did I do that
but John Jones at all every bit of six
all sports do that right all sports is
it yeah John six
six-five I'd say six five six four but
yeah hmm very intrigued right now steep
a John's the fight yeah very intrigued
but there's nothing for donít light
heavyweight
at heavyweight this now it was left at
hide light everywhere anybody there's
Rhea's vs. Weidman the winner that
outside that there's literally nothing
he's beat everyone one through like six
there's nothing nominal yeah you know
for John's legacy go up there and you
know get it man cars blades hmm
interesting
no you got nothing for any paper using
death cells be in the UFC you're doing
John for steep it you got a dejar steep
a depend what DC wants to do but DC's
out for a wild man interesting right did
he get injured or he's who's tapped for
a while deep a DC he's a frog who got
knocked down off down didn't he's also
for teeth um every time yeah it should
be
let me ask for a well great comment if I
was a rare head huh I just thought it's
got a great career ahead of him so we
know that's a great cuz amazing he's
good he doesn't need to do anything he's
amazing
DC one [ __ ] Kings wouldn't life man
hell yeah um good fight though yeah my
first gift card in line well an idea is
Tomas veto this is a hat huh yeah
that'll happen
if DFC pays Nate what he's worse the
otherwise you can have another long
holdout
mmm-hmm which is a bummer but if I'm if
I'm Mozilla I want to hold out for the
title shot I don't want to fight Nate
you're not getting that shot you see you
told that you're fighting me okay Kobe
Kobe use mine yep yep tell you this
right now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue oh good what's gonna happen what
are you gonna do use some of that boxing
you've been doing
[Laughter]